[Music]
homie look what I become
he's a Jeep but that's the best part
sometimes when you're somewhere randomly
you end up being in a clip with you
that's it and that's what Larry Elder
did anyways episode today's what Rob
what five shout out to Miami 305
special
guard
about its home team by the way just so
everybody knows this Thursday the
podcast this third Thursday is going to
be myself with two Muslims that I'm
invited to have a friendly discussion
with two folks who will go give their
perspective from the POV and challenges
they see a Muslim and Muslim friends are
going to come here have the discussion
which is going to be fantastic and then
I'm looking forward to that we've
already had a lot of discussions behind
closed doors for this to be done we'll
be doing many many more of these it'll
be myself with the four of them this
Thursday uh put that in your calendar
tomorrow 9 A.M we're launching the Tom
Brady interview is finally going to be
released tomorrow which is going to be
epic so for some of you that wanted to
really see it it's going to go out
tomorrow some of the things I asked Tom
which ring was more important The Seven
Rings was it more to get one more than
Belo check was it more important to get
one more than Michael you'll have to see
to see which one you think the answer
was but aside from that we've got a lot
of things to talk about today we got the
you uh the the UAW strike that's taking
place right now 13 000 employees workers
uh part of the uh uh Union uh went on a
strike it's not looking good we got a
lot of things to talk to you about with
that uh another one is man arrested and
uh suspected assassination attempt at
RFK Jr and wait till you see how quickly
the government moved to give a a Kennedy
who's running for president uh Secret
Service protection then Denver homeless
Camp features pop-up bars with rentable
ready prostitution tents okay we'll talk
about that nice a timetable of sexual
assault allegations again Russell Brand
uh Americans are least likely ready this
is from CNBC to care about kids having
good manners here's what they prioritize
instead we'll talk about that Donald
Trump likes the concept of picking a
female running mate for presidential
race Donald Trump wished liberal Jews a
happy New Year by accusing them of
destroying America that didn't make a
lot of people happy
this this there was about we have to
talk about Beetlejuice to show how
special it is I mean it's so special
it's arousing people it's exciting them
to to get down and dirty I love it and
fool around with each other have you
taken somebody on a baby
because of this situation can you
imagine you're gone you just say hey so
hey Mary would you like to go watch
Beetlejuice together you know that's
like your way of talking dirty she can
only imagine like oh my God it's going
down that's amazing you want to go to
dinner have a little stiff drink go out
to the club and everything and then just
just see a great play that just
penetrates the soul yeah that's right
there so calm again
AOC video shows AOC confronted by
Furious news uh New Yorkers uh Sanders
Bernie Sanders you guys ready for this
one serious discussions should take
place on the four day work week yes sir
we're gonna go work four days but get
paid for five days that math makes a lot
of sense what a the genius behind
socialists is just something else on a
whole different level Chinese spy a
threat to U.S Congress Amplified here's
another one then there were two
disappearance of second Chinese Minister
Sparks speculation Financial Times
zelinski guess what he's doing here he
came to his uh private Equity guys to
meet with them this private Equity Firm
is called the White House
like the automakers of a lot of crazy
things Biden Economic Policy have quite
quite made people's lives better this is
an Insider story then Fox news story
says voters say White House doing more
harm than good on inflation googlers two
words you can no longer use at Google
maybe we'll talk about that you can no
longer use words such as share and
bundle it's offensive she used those
words obviously the Jetta was missing
100 million dollar jet that went missing
I mean it's not a big deal you know it's
just hey whatever can you guys just look
for it can you interested
we'll give you a five dollar Starbucks
card
and it's the one with the most advanced
technology yeah yeah so it's not a
trainer the last but not least seven
thousand people arrive on Italian island
of six thousand oh my God as a migrant
crisis overwhelms something's got
lampedusa can you imagine guys there's
only six thousand people that's like 330
million people live in America 340
million people show up here it's like
migrants listen we got to take them we
got to take care of these guys anyways
all right let's go with the main story
here you uh a w strike will be felt
Beyond Detroit National Association of
Manufacturers warrants
this is not good on what's going on over
there uh uh the National Association of
Manufacturers has issued a warning about
the United Auto Workers strike against
Detroit's big three automakers for GM
and stalantis stalantis is like Chrysler
Fiat Jeep highlighting the broader
economic repercussions it may have
Beyond Detroit Nam president Jay Timmons
emphasized that the strike would affect
the integrated supply chain of small and
medium-sized manufacturers across the
country impacting both Union and
non-union shops and adding to the
economic pressures caused by high
inflation the potential Economic
Consequences of an extended strike are
significant with the estimates
suggesting that a full shutdown of
manufacturing operations at all three
automakers for just 10 days could cause
the U.S economy 5.6 billion dollars
individual automakers facing production
stoppages could incur weekly earning
losses of ready four to five hundred
million dollars Tom what is going on
here well the first thing is I think Rob
can probably find a chart somewhere on
this the whole UAW hasn't gone on strike
yet this is just a subset 13 000 of them
yes this is the photo op the members all
members is four hundred thousand this is
13 000 going on a strike so this is the
photo op to say we're freaking serious
and so here they come out for the photo
op but there's something else going on
here it's not like the big three didn't
see the contract negotiations coming and
it's not like the big three don't know
that in 2009 everybody except Ford a CEO
at the time Alan malali took U.S money
you're nodding Adam I hope I'm getting
that right during the recession yes only
and now it's not like the big three
didn't get some assistance during covid
they did and they've rebounded and made
some good prob profits moved over to EVS
so they saw this coming and maybe behind
closed doors they were trying to give
something maybe they weren't but the UAW
seems really pissed off which is
normally the way they wake up in the
morning anyway but but to me this is
just the photo op and yesterday the
quote was there could be more widespread
impact of this you saw that yesterday
I've seen what they're asking for and
have you seen what they are correct now
comes the punch line stalantis Chrysler
claims that they were on the right as
these pickets were coming out the photo
op was starting like the third day of it
stalana says we went in and offered 21
you know wage increase over I think 36
months they were like screw you we want
40 over was it it won 36 over four years
four years so Ford NGM offered 20 the
land is 17 and a half then they went to
21. now they're asking for 36 because
they're asking 36 because the CEO made
34 increase in her salary over the last
three or four years and they want the
similar growth for increase in their
salary as the CEO got so it's a little
bit of a a a a pickle on uh how they
want because they're seeing what
happened with uh with uh what do you
call it the UPS strike how successful
they were yeah great time to cap 100
Grand driving a brown truck that's right
and Biden's said Biden said I'm the I'm
going to be the biggest pro-union
president of all time and all these
unions are seen it as an opportunity to
capitalize off of it because the next
guy may not be a pro-union guy and Obama
came out of hiding and goes up there and
says you know they're making a lot of
profits here and I think it's time to
give some of those back and so he kind
of threw a little you know bacon on the
grease fire you know two days ago where
when he walked out and so you know
there's something to be said is there a
blend line here that says hey the Auto
industry bounced back a little bit
profits were up you know is it time to
negotiate this and do a little bit more
for workers especially at a time with
high inflation I think there is but I
also think that the UAW probably wasn't
having any of it you could have made the
best offer you wanted for them and I
think they were heading out the strike
yeah let me give a maybe a little more
context my dad's from Detroit my
family's from Detroit like I have family
friends in the Motor City baby I mean
that's you talk about the big three when
you you know I had to look who the hell
stalantis because it's Ford it's GM and
all of a sudden it's stalantis if you
remember their Daimler Chrysler they
they merged and was you know part of a
German company Daimler Chrysler whatever
but that's the big three and for many
many years this was what made America
tick you know starting with Henry Ford
and the uh the initial card that he made
what is it called the T the F whatever
it was Model T Model T there it is so
here's why it has implications of what's
going on because if you're out there and
be like dude I don't really give a
about the United Auto Workers I've never
even heard of these guys here's why this
matters number one it's gonna affect
uh 2024 and the election why because the
patented hit the nail on the head uh
here's a main story from Wall Street
Journal right now UAW strike collides
right with Biden's manufacturing agenda
so on one hand Biden is very
pro-union right he's pro-union and at
the other hand he's talking about
bringing manufacturing back specifically
in the EV sector right you did a whole
case study on Tesla uh what's going on
China competitive markets what's going
on with that so where is the UAW located
or where where are these cars being
built well the Rust Belt Michigan okay
uh Pennsylvania Ohio these are what is
known as Battleground states in the
election I mean 20 2008 2012 they won
Obama 2016 they went Trump 2020 they
went back to Biden this is arguably the
most important part of the country when
it comes to the electorate so if you're
like I don't really give a about a
car or whatever it it's going to affect
the election if you appease these people
or not especially the union so
um Biden you know he did everything with
the inflation reduction act which was
just sort of a a mini green new deal if
you recall that that's kind of how they
factored that and he also did the chips
act so this is all kind of part of the
manufacturing situation that's going on
in America all right now let's get down
to like what why this matters to you
beyond politically so you hit the nail
on the head there they want I think 35
40 raise over four years they want a 32
Hour Work Week interesting
um so they want to make more and work
less they don't want a 32 they want to
they want to work 32 hours but get paid
for 40 hours okay so it's not they want
a 32 hour work week they want to get
paid for 40 hours for 32 hours by the
way you know what so do I sir
you know that's like getting the great
rate that's like the great equalizer
raise on top of your money raise but
here's where this comes down to supply
and demand right when we talk about
raising the minimum wage we're talking
about you know fight for 15. what
happens if you pay these guys more okay
so the car prices if you've seen what's
going on with the car price I says Pat
don't worry I'm not gonna start
advocating everyone start ubering but
you should uh car prices since covet
have gone up 20 25 the average car
payment for a new car in 2019 was what
550 bucks now it's 750 bucks gas is at
an all-time high you know dealing with
that everything with Ukraine whatever
with that again bouncing again
so if you pay these guys more and they
basically succumb to demands how much
more are they going to charge the
consumers for cars and chips and auto
and everything with that so it's a
really slippery slope last Point here
um you talk about
um how much it's costing if they go on a
10-day strike the cost of the economy if
they go it costs five billion dollars a
day that's 15 to 20 billion dollars a
month that will be costing the economy
supply chain you know trucks drivers
everything that goes into that but
specifically the Auto industry could
lose between 400 and 500 million a week
that's two billion bucks a month and uh
the Auto industry makes up three percent
of America's total GDP couple things
here very good points by the way Rob can
you pull up that uh chart I sent you
that I think Tom used on a recent case
study here so private sector uni
membership has declined sharply in the
U.S look at this 1972 Tom pointed out it
was at 24.2 percent on the private
sector right now it's at six percent
what does this tell you Americans are
realizing stay the hell out of my
business Union by the way a couple
things you got to be thinking about
outside of this why is this such a big
deal so this this UAW was founded by
this guy named Walter reuter if you
don't know this guy's history he was the
president for like 24 years insane guy
he's John F Kennedy sent him to go
negotiate with the Castro on the you
know one of the hostages LBJ leveraged
the sky hardcore Richard Nixon said the
only way that John F Kennedy won is by
own a guy like this a favor this guy's
like Jimmy Hoff on steroids is who this
guy's Walter reuter he was killed me we
have two attempts on this assassination
he died on a plane crash he's like a
legit tough guy who was an incredible
politician if you hear him speak you're
going to say this guy could have run for
office he was that good at what he did
Walter reuter Rooter you couldn't
produce him any different way so so
here's here's what it gets technical in
the 88 years of this you know Union
being Iran and remember it's not just
cars it's 400 400 000 members because
it's many different industries that are
a part of it it's not just cars we're
talking about it's you know Automotive
Aerospace and other Industries so we say
Auto Workers but it's a massive Union
started small and now it's massive in
the 88 years there's never been a time
where these three companies have
simultaneously been targeted by strike
never in 88 years simultaneously it's
not been GM Ford and stalantis it you
know it's never happened before so
that's a big deal number two
a total of 61 plans have been announced
that they're going to be shut down 61
plus so you got GM saying 33 on their
own idle plans Ford's got 18 and you got
Fiat Chrysler is going to have another
10. this is going to affect around 50
000 jobs give or take uh the economy is
going to fill it now the the good news
bad news what's the what's the good news
the good news is the longest strike
they've had in the recent years was in
2019 it lasted 40 days okay they're
gonna have to figure figure out a way to
negotiate this what's the bad news the
bad news is there's a guy named Bob Iger
right now and there's another strike
going on with writers uh you know what
is the Actors Guild and actors that
they've been going I think writer's been
since May 12th which is almost four
months wow actors been since July 14th
or something so that's two months Bill
Maher wanted to bring his show back I
want to bring you back I'm not going to
bring you back it's not going to be as
good writers are going to be good Drew
Barrymore went through what she's going
through and then UPS got what they got
with the whole salary they're going to
make a hundred thousand dollars to be a
driver so again they're capitalizing
today the pressure is all on one party
and one individual right now okay the
party is the Democratic party and the
individual is Joe Biden yesterday uh
Stephen King tweeted something out if
you can go on Twitter Rob I retweeted
this guy yesterday he said the following
here's what he said yesterday on Twitter
Stephen King the writer Stephen King the
writer I can just go to my second tweet
if you go go up or go there you go they
go down a little bit go down a little
bit right they zoom in right there his
tweet is Mary Barra CEO of General
Motors makes 29 million a year I
retweeted and I say Stephen King The
King Of Horror as estimated net worth of
500 million okay so here's a guy that's
a socialist worth a half a billion
dollars talking about another girl
a female female CEO of a Fortune 500
company making 29 million dollars a year
which by the way good for them for
making their money good here's a crazy
thing to be thinking about one of the
reasons why I respected this guy named
Bob and Moshe AIG CEO I was there when
these guys went to the government and
asked for 183 billion dollars when AIG
was about to go out of business the
American International Group the most
hated company in America in 09 2010. it
was so bad that they would tell us when
you're selling Insurance don't say AIG
say American General don't use our logo
that's how bad it was wow
Bob and Moshe comes in we're in Chicago
at the Ritz Carlton I believe we're
having dinner it's my you know it's uh
uh David Herzog the CFO of AIG who used
to be the CFO I believe of American
general or was that anyways but he was
the CFO of AIG if you type in David
Herzog CEO CEO CFO you'll see God was
making very good money they come in they
asked for 183 billion dollars from the
government this guy's got three years
left to live Bob and Moshe he's on his
deathbed living at his Vineyard in
Croatia Dubrovnik used to be the former
CEO of MetLife okay what ends up
happening he comes back they take the
they end up paying the 183 back and 21
billion dollars of Interest give or take
and then he dies wow the announcement
was made at an award ceremony was on a
Friday night time I don't know if you
remember that I remember it very when
Mark Mark got up and he said got some
bad news for you Bob Ben Moshe has just
died but his legacy lives on so the part
where Stephen a king Stephen King has a
point is GM never paid the taxpayers
back and she's still making 29 million
dollars a year so socialist is trying to
make a point but unfortunately the point
where he's right is the fact that the
people that got money from the
government those are the same guys that
haven't paid back but AIG ended up
paying back and that guy's a true
capitalist there's a bunch of things
going on here with UAW what's gonna end
up happening here is there's a lot on
the line with politics I don't think
this is going to go that long I think
they're going to figure this thing out
fairly quickly I think 20 they're asking
for 36 percent uh you got to know what
this means if you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year you know where
you're gonna go to 136 if you're making
30 bucks an hour you're gonna go to 42
an hour 41 and if they give you the 36.
they'll eventually figure it out unlike
Hollywood where they're not caving these
guys will eventually have to Cave let me
just give you you hit the nail on the
head with uh how much money they're
making
um you know the biggest uh
potentially who can reap the benefits of
all this is none other than our friend
Elon Musk at Tesla why because they're
not Union you know you did you did the
whole uh thing at the CEO meeting and
what we're going to do the meetings as a
union is it not Union it was very
interesting Dynamic
um here's how much the average worker
gets paid in each of these companies
ready so this is according to the
Securities Exchange Commission the SEC
um Gary Gensler out there so the average
pay for a GM worker 80 grand a year for
GM the average pay for a Ford worker 75
grand a year stellantis Chrysler 68
Grand a year so those are the big three
so you're making between 68 and 80. so
I'll call it 70 to 80 grand interesting
according to the SEC you know how much
the average Tesla worker makes how much
half of that 34 grads 34 Grand so when
you talk when and now part of that is
because they have factories in China and
and uh Elon Musk has been sort of
avoiding you know unionized and what
right to work states that's a whole
other conversation that Tom that you've
done that but
um this is all part of the government
mandated EV agenda the EV race what's
going on with China the US you did a
whole thing about it but it's very
interesting and it has memory
modifications on your car and the
apology by the way I want to wrap it up
with this and got to go to the next door
because we're at 24 minutes in and we're
at one story last thing I'll tell you
about you know what's the close you know
what a union leader
a mother-in-law and lawyers have in
common
union leaders mother-in-law and lawyers
have in common let me give you
perspective mother-in-law comes in
wife is there she's spending time with
the mother-in-law
husbands at work and she says you know
I don't know about Larry he doesn't work
as hard as Johnny does your sister's
husband works very hard and Larry's not
a hard worker and I don't appreciate
what Larry does I think Larry should
treat you better that bag you have the
coach why doesn't he buy you a Louis
Vuitton because Johnny does oh my God I
hate this mother the wife is sitting
there and then the husband comes home
and when the husband comes home says hey
babe how you doing how am I doing yeah
well what do you think I was doing after
cleaning the house taking care of the
kids what kind of a husband are you why
can't you game me the person
like Johnny does and the husband's like
what are you talking about bro happens
it's a long ass day I want to deal with
this thing what are you talking about
babe he has no clue what happened but it
was the union leader AKA mother-in-law
now let's talk about another one husband
and wife are setting up a you know
nuptial agreement prenup she'll
agreement they're about to get married
he has to get his lawyer she has to get
her lawyers because that's how the code
works you can't get one lawyer to do the
nupture agreement you need one on each
side Lord years come in yeah for only
three thousand dollars we can get this
done it's not even a problem it's only
going to cost three thousand dollars
then you realize here's the future bride
here's a future groom they're about to
get married all of a sudden you realize
the lawyers are on the same team uh oh
your lawyer's not on your team her
lawyer is not on her team the lawyers
are on each other's team why because
here's what they do a wink let's start a
fight 22 additional hours times 400
bucks boom I'm sorry you got an eleven
thousand two hundred dollar bill it was
supposed to be three thousand dollars
but you know you fought for those miles
and you fought for all this stuff so
it's not eleven thousand miles so what
does union leaders do hey
it's not there
your boss is doing
think about what they're doing it's like
oh my God I have a horrible boss yeah
this is such a horrible situation I'm in
yeah boom all of a sudden the union
leader is your mother-in-law that's
what's going on with these union leaders
so when you when you think about their
job is to divide okay when you when you
think about many of the politicians on
the games they're playing their job is
to divide and then they conquer and then
they come in and say
hey hey Mr Union Leader I know you're so
worried about us and I'm having a hard
time paying a membership pay the
membership but we're going to take care
of you because we care about you but as
long as you paid a membership an
important but we care about you know as
long as but you got to pay the
membership can I go get another job
because I really need to you can't get
another job but no you can't get another
job because you know we have to be loyal
to one another but I need to go start a
show because I'm a talent and if I don't
create comedy I don't work what do I do
you got to be loyal to the union you got
to be good to the union you understand
what happens here that's what's going on
with the Union you know who they need by
the way and we'll wrap up they need the
two arbitrators from The Wedding
Crashers
shut your mouth
go to the next store let's go to the
next story all right a timeline of
sexual assault allegations against
Russell Brand here we go speaking of
principles here we go here we go the
next one is here next target folks it's
called guilty until proven innocent
modern day they've evolved it used to be
innocent until proven guilty now it's
guilty until proven innocent so where's
the story here it's okay okay we go
2006. this is a guardian story 2006 a
woman alleges that Russell Brand
sexually assaulted her during a
three-month relationship when she was 16
years old and bran was 30 years old
uh was a BBC radio presenter she
described him as controlling and
emotionally abusive she said he referred
to her as the child and advised her to
lie to her parents leading to
allegations of grooming that's 2006 in
London okay 2007. Jordan Martin claims
brand sexually assaulted her and was
physically and emotionally abusive
during a six-month relationship she
detailed in an incident at a Manchester
hotel where bran became angry and
assaulted or Martin published these
allegations in a book in 2014 which bran
has never challenged 2012. woman alleges
that brand raped her at his Los Angeles
home in July 2012 she claimed he blocked
her from leaving and apologizing via
text message afterwards she received
therapy treatment but decided against
pursuant legal action 2013 a woman who
met brand at an Alcoholics Anonymous
meeting accuses him of sexually
assaulting her at his La home she
claimed he tried to kiss her and remove
her clothes and when she resisted he
shouted at her and later threatened her
with legal action if she spoke at 2020
the woman who alleged sexual Assad
during her underage relationship with
bran contacted his literary agent who
denied the allegations brand talent
agency
Tavistock would initially supported him
but later terminated all professional
ties with him stating they were misled
2023 a joint investigation by the time
Sunday times and channel 4 dispatch is
detailed multiple allegations against
Brent he denied the claims in a video
posted online which got 70 million views
asserting that all his relationships
were consensuals and accusing the media
of coordinated attack Adam yeah well
where have I've seen this Playbook
before who have we done some interviews
with that you know made a major name for
themselves was talking about the Matrix
was talking about does it rhyme with
brand you great it does yeah we this
reminds me eerily weird of what happened
with Andrew Tate but by the way this is
the Playbook ladies and gentlemen you
know if you speak against the narrative
if you speak against whether it's big
Pharma or as Alex Jones says the
globalists in the New World in a new
world order
yeah that's yeah this is what they do
right so you know we'll probably discuss
a story about how they tried to
assassinate RFK Jr that was the old
school Playbook whether it's RFK or
Bobby Kennedy or Martin Luther King they
just full on kill you now it's character
assassination we've talked about this a
million times on the podcast but what's
interesting about me is
all these allegations allegations
Anonymous people they're from 15 years
ago they didn't want to bring this up 15
years ago all of a sudden Russell Brand
I think he's got like what six million
YouTube subscribers we did his show a
couple weeks ago I want to say right was
that which got suspended him by the way
Adam if you can't make no money right
now get out of here this morning that
actually yeah this is what they do guys
there's two things first of all to
Adam's Point these things happened 15
years ago and let's not forget in
between the 15 years when these
accusations happened today there was a
giant movement in the United States
called the meat correct everyone where
it was believe all women yeah and these
women failed to come out then and my
favorite is yesterday Newsweek publishes
this story Jimmy Fallon failed to stop
Russell Brand harassing Catherine McPhee
this is yesterday this is an old video
from a Tonight Show appearance
appearance same day Catherine McPhee
denies Russell Brand made her feel
uncomfortable on tonight show appearance
yeah so you have one Outlet repeating
that it's uncomfortable and making you
feel sexualized and then another news
Outlet going no there's nothing wrong
here yeah and I think it's two major
news outlets that have been going after
him it's uh the times and then uh
channel four both I think in in Britain
right there but this is what's happening
right now and at the same time there's
someone gonna be watching this it's like
well what happens if you did it what
happens if he did it okay prove it yeah
uh you know whether it's Harvey
Weinstein or Bill Cosby yeah there are
some legitimate scumbags out there but
what yeah what we've also learned is
that no it's not believe all women or
don't trust all men it's a very nuanced
individual situation and Russell Brand
who has publicly said yeah dude I I was
out there I was a Hollywood movie star
I'm with a bunch of children thousands
of women yeah like thousands now like
your average when you have this is my
opinion come at me when you have that
much access to women and celebrity and
fun you don't need to rape and pillage
like you're some Dirtbag and so and he
doesn't strike me as a type of person
who's like power hungry he speaks truth
to power and not and not condoning this
or whatever it's just it is what it is
16 years old Pat is the age of consent
in England let's just I'm not sticking
up for that that's not my that's my bag
do you know where it also is uh the age
of consent what uh in 35 states in
America yeah did you know that no I
thought it was 18 and over in every
single state because Florida and I'm not
condoning hanging out with a 16 year old
but you know in New York it's it's
actually 16. California it's 18. every
state it
75 in the America United States of
America
it's a lot of seniors it's 44.41 yeah
but but I I just I think we have a
problem especially when people say
that's a joke yeah
you know that's against my rules the 40
plus correct I'm sick and tired of
hearing innocent it's improving guilty
because that's in the public eye you're
guilty and the fact when I saw this me
uh this newsstand in England everything
is all going after him and I don't care
what anybody says path right now right
now on all the magazines it showed
Patrick's face and said rape act you
said he's a rapist that's it I don't
care what you're gonna say and like you
said Adam we saw it with Brett Kavanaugh
we saw it with Julian Assange who's
rotting away into prison because they're
telling us the truth uh Andrew Tate said
uh welcome to the club it goes down
right they don't like competition is
what must go they don't like he's being
targeted by coordinated Media Tech for
his right-wing criticism and Tucker said
criticize the drug companies and
question the war in Ukraine and you can
be pretty sure that this is going to
happen
this documentary for Tom out of the five
women are in the shadows this revealing
crazy documentation which just so
happens to be ready to go to make money
and it's like
you're sitting in the in the shadows
it's it's hard if you can't see the
person's face it's hard to see their
truth like I want to see who's talking
it's like all these uh Anonymous
whistleblowers they're like no no you
can't see them but trust us behind this
door there's people saying that you did
what you did I again I don't know
because I wasn't there let it let it all
come out but it's just it's just weird
that all this happens once you start
speaking the truth and I think I
mentioned this to you yesterday you're
not really poking the bear unless this
happens he's saying he's affecting their
wallets he's messing with big Pharma and
they just hit one little switch boom
that's it he he the behind they loved
them a few years ago when he was a
liberal uh Playboy he called Kitty
Hawkins he called her Hitler he stormed
into everything called her Hitler he's
like oh he's so cool hey yo not the
shirt you know he's just take my eyes
but not the shirt right you know the
question becomes how about this guy
named Schofield who work for BBC oh yeah
he's dealing with mental issues he's
having problems it's so challenging with
all the pressure he's got to do he was
messing with diddling kids grooming a 16
year old boy which comes his mom is
upset and he's going oh no no BBC okay
okay and then you got this Hugh Edwards
guy pain you know I don't know if you
read this I'm wrong with you Edwards
what he's doing no but you know life is
challenging for those guys but God
forbid Russell Brand comes out and says
what he said they're going to be
targeting the guy again
if he's done what he's done the lawyers
got to do their jobs but you got to
prove my biggest problem here is the
following is to jump to conclusion
society that we're living in right now
before anybody is accused of it being
right or wrong immediately boom
allegations nope they're guilty we did
this with politics in 2016 where
somebody was uh you know claimed he had
been Russia collusion for three years
and everybody bought into it and we had
believed with Tate what's going on
believe with so many different people
this doesn't mean it can't be true we
just can't jump to conclusion believe in
everything but when they when a guy like
him goes out there as loud as he is has
been hooking up for as long as he has
all of a sudden he calls out a few
people beautiful targets you want to
know what's crazy why don't you hear
these types of allegations come out
against someone like Dan Bilzerian right
or even Leonardo DiCaprio does anybody
get more ass than those two guys no but
here's the difference they stay in their
Lane they don't say anything Leo is a
huge advocate of uh animals of animals
and and the green uh energy and that's
great that he's Hollywood good for him
so as long as he's in speaker against
any narrative so are you saying like
Russell should do a video with animals
he should pen like
not a sexual position you even look at
someone like Dan Bilzerian that guy does
two things tries to make money and he
tries to hook up you know yeah do his
thing but once you start talking about
the things that Russell Brand talks
about that Andrew Tate talks about that
Alex Jones talks about whether you think
it's right or wrong once you start
talking about these things by the way
the people paying the bills up top
they're gonna come out you know who wins
here two companies X and Rumble that's
who wins here thousands two companies
you you demonetize this guy two
companies win Exxon Rumble let's talk
about an economy story uh ball Bears
lover on gay-friendly Aspen bar
Beau bear is that what you're calling
her is it Lauren bobert is it bobert can
I pronounce the way I pronounce it or do
I have to do it like
all the words you pronounced uh first of
all yours is this the story of her going
to it or isn't this the story that I'm
telling yeah
believe all women before you even say
this so Lauren would never lie Lauren
bobert yes a Republican representative
is romantically involved with Quinn
Gallagher the co-owner of Hooch craft
cocktail bar in Aspen known for hosting
drag shows bobairs previously critical
of uh drag was captured engaging in
public affection with Gallagher who
profits from drag performances she
comments on drag including uh include
tweets like take your children to church
not to drag bars video footage from a
theater outing in Denver showed Quinn
Gallagher fun fondling Lauren's uh
breast which ignited controversy
initially denying the claims she later
attributed her behavior to her public
and difficult divorce and issued an
apology saying the past few days have
been very difficult and humbling and I'm
truly sorry the incident at the theater
involved disruptive behavior Behavior
vaping and recording the show leading to
police involvement first of all I don't
know if you know this or not speaking of
her she's single as of this morning she
broke up with that no that guy so Lord
is this that's look at look at that
first of all she dude what a fun girl
listen but mind you though this is by
the way this is in the dark this is he
rubbing her tits yeah she's grabbing his
cross but no straight up is that
actually what's happening real Adam
that's real is this your first time
seeing it that's your first time I saw
her vaping I didn't realize there was
something great but here's the thing hey
Lauren if you're listening I'm on the
market I'm a big fan of your politics
but listen so I just find it funny that
this whole ordeal Pat and like we just
saw it it's recorded on multiple night
vision cameras CNN they contact CNN
immediately all right it's a big big
story but you know what when it comes to
the West Wing Outside The Situation Room
they find a big bag of booger sugar
guess what no cameras nobody knows
what's going on nobody knows what's
going on so theater has better camera
equipment than the White House oh that
makes a lot of sense common sense and
they've got uh they've got uh infrared
so you can see people at night and
everything like that and it's not the
White House though yeah no they're the
ones old blurry cameras anytime it's the
white house or like Epstein's prison
cell there's no kid they weren't working
that day or nothing worked I thought
about it and she she should have brought
Hunter Biden with her that this wouldn't
you never would have seen and none of
this would have been what an idea I'm
not gonna let's just be honest she just
got divorced I think she has four or
five kids Rob same with you she's a
little hottie and she has fun she's
vaping grabbing boobs I'm that listen
Lauren I'm single so I'm gonna message I
love her she's fun what are the chances
that Hunter bidens and her DMs he's
probably in there right now he's
probably what are the chances saying
that guy doesn't know how to party like
you know my kind of let's go do
something yeah and guess what there's no
amateur dump the amateur yeah right here
what do you Tom what do you think about
this honestly what do you think about
this it's all the jokes aside it's all
the jokes aside I think there's another
side to this and that is she knows that
she is writing the third rail and for
those of you that don't know the um
Subway that's one of the electricity the
dangerous one she's right next to the
third rail every time she makes a speech
in Washington because she is number one
was anti-establishment number two was
conservative and number three writing
the third rail she's like an intro
there's a third guy involved she was an
inch away maybe maybe I I don't know
let's unfortunate Middle Eastern what is
a third round break it down
third guy if someone falls off the
subway yeah you got to reach down and
you scream at him don't touch the third
rail it's one in the middle so she
shouldn't have touched it she should not
have touched it and so what this is is
is you're a congresswoman you got to
know with your background and what you
stand for that they are looking for you
to to trip and to do anything and to not
say thank you when you hold the business
honestly does this hurt her political
one million
it does this is not good I if I was if I
was on her team you know I I would be
saying Lauren what are you doing they're
looking for you in every moment You're
The Devil's Advocate you just gave them
three things I know you want to go out
and have a good time and you're getting
divorced as a new boyfriend I get it
Lauren but you don't have to to to put
yourself in a position where you're
giving them ammunition you want to be
the third rail now go ahead no go ahead
what's yours well so you say this hurts
her career why how is any of this
helpful she's she's number one full-on
lying 1 000 votes okay okay but that's
some that's politics though no I'm
politics aside by the way Rock keeps
playing this right are you playing this
for us or for yourself buddy
you
know hang on put your pants on dude okay
to give Robin we'll go good bad ugly
here so in terms of politics yeah she's
probably one of the more attractive
Congress women okay at the same time
vintage is also 36 with four kids she's
36 on 40 day away right now Pat huge
finish I'm not joking you're not ready
to be a step down whatever I'm messaging
her right but she's in she's in Colorado
which has gone from red to purple to
full-on Blue these days she's in a red
District that's the only reason she's
got elected but this doesn't help her so
um she was asked number one this
happened at the Beetlejuice situation if
you've never seen the movie Beetlejuice
it was a musical yeah the musical of the
real juice Beetlejuice yeah great movie
Michael Keaton amazing Beetlejuice
beetles but she was accused of vaping
the some lady behind her who was
apparently pregnant was like hey can you
stop vaping she's like yeah do what I
want to do whatever
allegedly she was like no I wasn't
vaping uh she's like it was the fog
machines it's like no clearly you're
vaping yeah you lied yeah it caught you
in a lie not a good look and we all know
politicians lie but this is on camera
but then she um she was asked to leave
for whatever she was taking selfies in
the middle of the night uh she they
they're basically they kicked her out
and she gave the classic don't you know
who I am thing and they go no we know
exactly who you are yeah representative
Beau bear bobert and uh we uh we you get
the hell out of here she flipped up the
middle finger it's drama this isn't good
a good look but look if you're a public
figure you obviously have the entitled
to your private life I get it but when
you're giving handes vape and getting
your titties rubbed at a public venue in
the dark it's pitch black she doesn't
think people are recording her and then
they're calling CNN so you're saying
that she should be doing that because
it's dark no no what I'm saying she
shouldn't be doing that no what I'm
saying okay this I get the vaping
triggered them to watch but dude
multiple cameras it's not like by the
way we're watching it Like Pat said this
is in night vision nobody is seeing it
yeah you know you know who has night
vision cameras every theater because
it's always at dark except the White
House
but Adam here's the thing well played
she's get she's gonna get fans the
younger crowd the younger guys are
definitely gonna be fans and guess what
they're gonna be they're gonna be trying
to slide in their DM I just message her
no here's the thing that's serious and
even if it doesn't work out you know
what the beauty about today in this
culture is she could go to only fans and
she would make a killing after this that
is probably what her future that's well
God bless you bring it up if she gets me
you think she's done done
when is she up for re-election I don't
she's a representative so it's every two
years
you're right coming up for reelection
she is absolutely a pubic figure public
figure and um 62 year old child over
here I love it and um
she won the last election by less than a
thousand votes yeah so it's not like
it's not like she's Teddy Kennedy in
Boston and you're gonna get 82 yeah
every time there's a lot going on here
pack can you tell Rob to put his pants
on like it's gotten to the point where I
came and looked at the computer we all
know that I think what's the percentage
of political ads that are negative she
won by more than 26 500 votes oh that
nearly retained her seat against the
Republican Legends and their only
retainer seat Again by a few hundred and
six hundred total oh wow
the election pass so that was the
re-election wow that's a mess and we all
know that I think 75 of political ads
are negative look what Donald Trump did
yeah Joe Biden's falling apart like it's
all negative dude you know I love you've
spent a million bucks on ads showing her
given a handy during Beetlejuice or Ruby
whatever it was it wasn't it's not a
good look it's Unbecoming of office
right but I message her and wait for her
she's like what's up you up
anyway this is uh I'm a fan but listen
even though she lied about this clearly
you got to believe all women you're damn
right okay all right next story next
story we go here what is a woman uh what
do you want to go to next you want to go
to AOC or you want to go to NOLA
suzalinski guys zelinski went and met up
with his private Equity Camp to raise
the money he's coming in to collect this
money from the PE firm it's not
BlackRock it's not uh State Street it's
not Vanguard it's called The White House
nice zilinski to meet U.S senators would
Ukraine Aid under threat so in other
words he's coming to say you haven't
paid your debt what are we waiting for
Ukrainian president uh zielinski is set
to me with the top U.S Senate leaders
including Chuck Schumer and Mitch
McConnell during his visit to Washington
the meeting is aimed to securing renewed
commitments from the U.S to assist
Ukraine in its effort to regain
territory occupied by Russia the meeting
in Congress comes as a House Republicans
are preparing to block a Biden
Administration request for an additional
24 billion dollars in Ukraine Aid with a
deadline of September 30 at 40 and that
a fiscal year conservative hardliners in
the house have threatened a government
shutdown of the budget deal includes
more A2 Ukraine zielinski has been vocal
about Ukraine's need for additional
Weaponry emphasizing the importance of
modern system and restoring the
country's territorial Integrity so he's
coming in other words to say I need more
money pay up if you don't you know this
is going to hurt you because your people
going to have to come and fight and your
kids are going to come and have to fight
and he's going to use the guild tactic
to get people to want to pay the money
to it so Tom what do you think is going
to end up happening here with this
zelinski visit well there's two things
that are coming together and you
mentioned one of them we have another
debt deal that's right just that quick
we have another debt deal and they made
and zelinski's
um I you know I think there's nefarious
things going on here you know you just
send money not arms why don't you just
send money that's been turned into
weapons I mean but instead we're sending
all this Aid and it sure doesn't look
like it's getting to the people I think
number one this is this is exactly what
Kevin McCarthy needed
um one of the things because he's got to
get the debt deal on by the way
the U.S just crossed
like in the last week 33 trillion events
so we went 33. and since
our great legislators our congressmen
representing us since the debt ceiling
crisis and the deal they made they've
managed to keep that credit card down to
1 trillion per month and over the last
five years they've added 11.5 trillion
so 33 percent of the of the 33 trillion
have been added in just the last five
years since they made a debt deal for
the rest of us and I think the newer
debt Deals they just they got to have
some leverage and all this is is Kevin
McCarthy saying I'm going to get what I
want in there and this isn't necessarily
going to bring the debt down I'm going
to get what I want in there zelensi is
going to get some of this the Biden
Administration is going to make sure he
gets some of this but it means McCarthy
is also going to get stuff that that his
side wants and once again the can gets
kicked down the road on the American Tax
Bill like is it just is it ridiculous
like we've created a monster the guy is
is countries in war right now right he's
flying here because we said hey we're
going to give you money the guy's flying
here to be like says Hey listen I know
you said you were giving me this gift
where the hell is it you understand like
where we've gotten in our country time
we're a president of a different country
that we said yeah we're gonna give you
money at some point but one side is
saying nah we can't afford it right now
you're getting on a plane to come here
to be like yo yo yo can't stand that Pat
is that and not just by the way you know
you know what it is it's kind of like
when you have money and you go
restaurant with your friends and
everybody expects you to get the bill
exactly it's like when you're you go out
with your family members or family
members come to you and saying you have
the money why don't you pay for it it's
like three siblings the sister makes the
most money she's an executive she got a
degree MBA she makes 280 a year the
other two siblings younger brothers
they're not really workers one makes 120
one makes 60. they say Hey sister since
you're the CEO of XYZ company you make
all the money mom just died you paid for
the funeral calls you have all the money
we don't it's an entitled attitude to
come and demand money it's as if he has
something on somebody in the White House
to say you better pay up or else it's as
if not as as if as if so there there's a
part of it that makes me feel very
uncomfortable go ahead let me give a
little perspective here because
um by the way when do you think this is
going to come to a head well he's coming
next week no no like this entire
situation with
with Ukraine January of 2025 if there's
correct president correct uh this is not
getting resolved in the next three six
months this is going to be you know we
talk about the culture wars that's going
on in America right that's going to be
hot button issues during the election
abortion
LGBT trans everything critical race this
is actual Wars right and the American
people are going to have a vote because
you're going to assume that Biden is
going to double down on this obviously
if he makes it to the debate stage of
this is why we need to be here this is
what we got to protect NATO we gotta
protect democracies you can't just
invade countries there's going to be a
narrative no doubt and then Trump I'm
assuming is going to say I could fix
this in one day there would be no war
without me Putin's my guy like you know
he's going to give obviously a
completely different narrative and the
American people
rightfully so are going to have the
ability to decide do you want to keep
giving money to the Ukraine or not but
it's not just money it's three things
because actually Rob shout out to you
did some research this is actually as of
this summer so it might be a couple
months old but United States by Far and
Away has given the most to Ukraine yeah
you talk about the big three big three
Auto here are the big three ways that um
countries not just the United States
have donated
um
money invested uh exactly invested so
it's it's military
financial and humanitarian so uh sixty
percent of the United States have done
has been military aid uh 30 financial
and 10
humanitarian but listen it's as much as
it is a White House issue
it's not like United States is just
funding this alone combined the EU UK
Germany Japan Canada Poland Netherlands
Norway Denmark Sweden France Italy
Finland Czech Republic Austria Spain
Slovakia South Korea Lithuania and
Belgium have all given massive amounts
of money whether it's in military
Financial or humanitarian so this is not
a just a U.S thing but it should be for
us but it's also the EU and everyone
across the globe you should give it you
should give the most they're not why
should we give them all well I think as
we all know with NATO it's a percentage
of GDP the reason that we have this I'm
not saying that it's right or wrong we
have the second highest percentage that
we give and at the same time America's
got a bunch of that we're dealing
with we have to make that a priority
now we're giving we're giving this guy
stage time to come to us and say I need
more money
what do you mean would give any more
stage time to come and pick for more
money how much more money do you need to
give what else do you want us to send to
you while our military gets weaker while
we have planes that are flying around
with a pilot that's ejected and we're
getting a message saying by the way if
you guys find anything we just let us
know because we can't find them greatest
military in the world
you're playing in your backyard don't
touch it call this number unbelievable
right it's like hey okay yeah yeah yeah
so we're definitely showing the world
how strong we are with what we got going
on but hey if you don't give me more
money where is your humanitarian we're
going through such struggles in Ukraine
is what we need more money okay all
right a little bit yes a lot of money
we've given you plenty how many how much
more do we need to give I kind of like
the fact they're trying to hold back a
little bit on the amount of money they
want to give and uh you know uh
support's been given plenty for you to
keep coming and then using like your you
know all these other tactics I'm just
not a fan of a guy what he's doing I
know we need to move on
um but
look for me it's not zero or a hundred
okay like Candace Owens I I love that
conversation that we had with Candace
last Thursday it was amazing she's like
zero nothing zilch that's not happening
like f them whatsoever then it's like
what's the slippery slope with that if
China invades Taiwan we do nothing you
know God forbid there's another world
where we do nothing are we
non-interventionalists are we completely
libertarian that approach or we policing
the world involved with everybody
850 bases around the world 780 80. okay
so like which one is it there needs to
be some Nuance here and at the end of
the day the American people the American
people American people are gonna make
this decision or do you want to be more
involved you want to be less involved
we can't just have a blank check for
this like Afghanistan let's go to the
next story man arrested and suspected
assassination attempt at RFK Junior
event uh posing if you can play this
video Rob so people can see it while I'm
reading this it'd be great RFK demanded
Secret Service protection from President
Biden after an armed gunman posing as
security team members was arrested at an
event just two miles from the site of
his father's assassination in 1960 uh it
says a father's assassination 1968 the
armed suspect carrying unloaded pistols
and a U.S Marshal badge attempted to
approach RFK during a Hispanic Heritage
Month event in La quick thinking
security Personnel from Gavin debecker
an associate gdba detained the man until
LAPD arrived to make the arrest RFK Jr
who is a long shot for the 2024
Democratic nomination expressed
frustration with the White House for
denying his earlier request for Secret
Service protection saying I'm the first
presidential candidate in history to
whom the White House has denied a
request for protection uh Vinnie what
else you got on the score well first of
all Pat what a weird what a weirdness as
a law enforcement anybody out there
that's law enforcement I'm pretty sure
you know this why why aren't you
disarming the guy he has two guns under
his armpits okay they're not taking away
his guns they're not he's posing as a US
Mark is that him right there that's him
right there bro and what he was dressed
as a U.S Marshal and it boggles my mind
oh look at he's got the whole badge
and oh yeah oh he just oh no 100 he went
for it here's my thing how is this not a
huge story or or even bigger because say
what you want Adam this is an assassin
why is this guy trying to get close to
him I had I had people from Cali that
are like how do you know he was just you
know not trying to get close to I go
protect what he is has two guns you know
what his motive is okay that's one thing
the second thing uh Not only was his
uncle murdered assassinated and we're
finding out what the CIA had involvement
his father was two miles away and it's
like the guy's begging rfk's begging he
goes I'm still entertaining the hope
that Joe Biden they'll give me Secret
Service protection and just just a
little fun fact I'll give you guys
normally the agency protects major
candidates for President and Vice
President within 120 days of the
election ironically these measures were
put in place after they killed Robert
Kennedy Obama was the first presidential
candidate in history to receive Secret
Service protection almost two years
prior two years he had had it the fact
that they're denying Adam would that to
me the average person that says what you
don't you just don't care and Pat I sent
this clip to Rob of uh JFK going into
his motorcade right before he was
assassinated there's two Secret Service
guys the main detail guys Pat there on
the back the agent in charge Emory
Roberts waves off two of the most
important bodyguards and and he's
obviously confused about it yeah rob you
can fast forward Just a Touch like you
could tell Pat that this guy Adam was
not in on the don't run next to the the
motorcade look at this you put the
volume up
look at this guy
this guy normal look that is up until
this instant he's supposed to run to
protect him back look he's like what
four more times yeah let him play one
more time he's like wait a minute and
now he's gonna go and he gets
assassinated those two guys are
important to block bullets coming from
the back he stopped running yeah watch
Adam Jesus and watch this check this out
Henry Roberts is coming a secret service
follow-up they have no clue what's about
that with his hand what he is doing is
calling away the president's two most
important bodyguards look it's a
bodyguards whose job was to protect the
president's back by riding the bumper of
the limit look at that he just like he's
like wait wait what and then look at him
and then he's going to his death so so
and my point being Pat in this day and
age this is RF Kennedy like he has a
history his family has been assassinated
and you're you're denying him Secret
Service what was the 120 days thing that
you so uh uh the agency the Secret
Service protects major candidates for
president and vice president he's a
major pre- 120 days within election time
I got it two years prior because it's
Obama they can't they gotta protect him
to re-election no no no no no no
election first one first one which is uh
so in 2007 2008 when he run he started
getting Secret Service in 2005 six six
before 2006 yeah so he was that
basically he was anointed exactly but
interesting my only thing is if you're
not protecting the guy after the history
of his family with assassination and
murder with government involvement it's
kind of shady business you're absolutely
right and God forbid anything would
happen to RFK Jr uh this would be blood
would be on Biden administrations okay
you think I'm just well of course I mean
look this is the only other
candidate that is challenging Joe Biden
and it's not even close obviously Joe
Biden you know makes it to the state
re-election that he's the guy you know
he's not doing any debates RFK
is he's out there but he's I don't know
is he polling it 17 20 Biden's it it's
like a trump Biden uh collision course
we know that but you know one of the
more one of the more famous speeches
that I remember from RFK recently was
when he was talking about gun violence
in America and basically framing it as
far as a uh opioid drug mental health
situation and he's like look I've lost
two family members to gun violence and
it makes you think you're like all right
who are the two family members well my
dad uh Bobby Kennedy and my uncle JFK
yeah so if there's anybody that
understands gun violence and
assassinations it would be this guy yeah
JFK at the time of his death was 46 RFK
was 42 JFK Jr uh was 38 he died in a
plane crash RFK 69. so um he's beaten
the odds and let's make sure that he's
at least protected yep okay next story
Americans are least likely to care about
kids having good manners here's what
they prioritize Instead This is again a
Sam NBC story
uh in 2017 only 52 percent of adults in
U.S considered good manners as an
important quality for children a
significant drop from 1990 when it was
76 percent Rob can you pull up this
article from 76 percent to 52 according
to a report by King's College London
this makes the U.S the least likely
country among 24 survey to prioritize
good manners in contrast Egypt leads
with 96 percent considering good manners
crucial followed by Nigeria 89 percent
obedience is less valued in the U.S with
only 21 seeing it as important for kids
Nigeria tops the list at 58 percent the
report highlights that the importance of
the obedience has declined in the
Western Country since 90s with the U.S
dropping from 39 to 21 percent besides
good manners and obedience the U.S value
hard work 68 Independence 56 percent
imagination 30 religious Faith 32
percent amongst children however
tolerance and respect for others 71 are
most commonly considered important
though the U.S ranks 11th in this
category Tom what are your thoughts on
this
you can see it every day the bizdoc Babe
is a teacher and we see it all the time
we've entered an era where it seems to
be more important that your kids are
happy and satiated right keep them happy
oh why isn't he happy and you see the
stories of parents at the you know
bribing a kid with ice cream to keep him
from having the Tantrum you've seen it
on airplanes we've seen it in malls and
over the last 20 years this new
generation it's about being happy and
satiated and it's because the parents
are not worried about the manners and
discipline they're worried about keeping
their kid happy they're worried about
satiating them there's a word for this
it's called spoiled
the discipline that comes with it kids
that have rails it's a fact that they
are content and there's a word for this
disciplined they're they're content and
their disciplined they know their rails
and they have happy little lives from
that side of it when parents don't care
about their kids and and you see the
drop in what we think about good manners
they're not worried about the manners
they're worried about just keeping the
kid quiet and bribing them and and
they're spoiling kids they're not
building good citizens and when you look
at this list of things it's exactly
flipped from you know from the 80s you
know I I wasn't allowed to do tantrums
and my mom was not you know some
horrible person I was not permitted to
do that and by the way if I threw a
tantrum somebody else's mom oh wait I'll
tell you something this is great so I am
six years old I have now just started
first grade and we're in St Louis
Missouri a little town called Creve
Coeur and I take like two of my little
comic books and I put them in this bag
and I'm walking down the street and I'm
like nine houses from where I live this
guy comes around the corner and I don't
remember the last name but he rolls down
there wasn't and he says Tommy where are
you going it says I'm mad I'm running
away he stops his car gets out and
stands up and says go home because he
knew where I lived and he just yelled
and pointed down the street he didn't
spank me didn't do anything like that
but he he exerted parental Authority you
know what I did I turned around and
walked back home and as I'm turning
around he says I'm calling your mom
she'll be ready when you're there and so
he's going to his house to call my mom
and so I didn't turn out terrible but
the point is now people are worried
about oh you know you don't worry about
manners you worry about oh does he want
to be a boy want to be a girl oh the
little boy wants to be a girl give me
the dick saw here we go oh you know yeah
well yeah right I don't know what the
name for the medical tool is I just made
that up I just think it says
I think it says a lot about Tom that
even at that age he's running away and
he's like I'm bringing reading and
I'm like I'm you know what the hell with
the underwear and I'm bringing
comic books
six years old brilliant I really wanted
to have this conversation I really
wanted to hit this topic because I think
it's sort of indicative of where we're
at in society is how great as America is
of everything that we've done in our
economy and the world and Innovation and
GDP and capitalism and free markets you
know uh we we are the Envy of the world
nobody's trying to come to any other
country other than America as the
American group we talk about immigration
which is a show these days but
everyone wants to come to America but
when you get to America you realize
there's something kind of going on here
that ain't right these days okay and a
lot of it has sort of been influenced by
the suit by sort of what's going on in
social media for sure which has been
good and bad for some reasons you know
part of the uh one of the big things
that I talk about on my show all the
time is this Wall Street Journal we've
talked about here is that the uh the
Americans pulling back from the values
that wants to find us so there's been
you know patriotism is immensely on the
decline having children is immensely on
the decline and raising children
obviously that's a whole other
conversation religion's on the decline
community involvements on on the decline
but what's up is money and looking out
for yourself and selfishness and taking
selfies for that matter so what I love
about America is personal responsibility
and what we call Rugged individualism
but also and I don't necessarily believe
in the collectivism uh socialism but
there is some sort of collective
collectivism of you know it takes a
village to raise a child and I think
what we need to bring back in America
are ass whoopings because it's so easy
for any kid to go online and just talk
with zero accountability did you
see the latest interview that Tate did
with the Aiden Ross kid and the kid that
he brought on with him did you see this
door okay that freaking dork in a
SpongeBob outfit he's sold 15 years old
talking to Andrew Tate being like
I'll kick your ass bro and Tate
like a G is like oh really bro uh is
that a SpongeBob shirt you're wearing as
he's literally hitting his inhaler to
breathe he's like yeah I know how hard
it is to breathe air these days it but
the reality is this because of social
media you have these kids that blow up
online that have never have to leave
their house face zero consequences can
talk online all day as Drake says
uh trigger fingers turn to Twitter
better fingers you can act tough and
this kid right here can be punching on
the skin the green shirt look at this
freaking dork just talking what an
alpha to Tate look at this kid what an
alpha and he's like oh yeah I'll come
over there kick your ass really bro yeah
okay that's just I think that's for
eyeballs though but that's my point is
that that kid is an influencer he's like
is that a so a kid like that so what's
your name like that is a kid like that
in the real world when we were growing
up in the 80s if you talk like that
in public to an Andrew Tate he wouldn't
be walking right back I'm saying bring
back ass whoopings and and just and I
think the reason I know Adam's not I
know people can be like oh Adam's saying
beat your kids no no as all of us did
all right
there was consequences to your actions
Like Pat if you're if our parents yeah
don't don't touch this and you went when
once you got that you learned it's
almost like the Pavlov dog Theory you
knew not to do that it wasn't like I was
bleeding or or there was no fear so now
those kids once now they realize oh
they're not gonna I could touch this and
nothing's gonna happen that's where you
have kids now because the parents are
disarmed the parents they call the cops
on on their parents now now a kid goes
from I could touch this I could stay I
could do what I want you know what in
school they're telling me I could be a
girl I'm a girl and the parents like
okay okay there's no discipline and
you're right Adam I think they should we
should have a national whoop your kids
ass dead We're Not Gonna donate them no
I want to obviously get past the pain as
a parent let me just say one thing
disclaimer I don't have kids uh all my
best friends have kids I hang out with
them every weekend I'm around all these
kids I was a teacher for two years I
taught second grade I taught seventh
grade okay I was at Camp concert I've
been around kids and
um something is going on especially
because of social media and bring make
America great again make ass whoopings a
great again I love it yeah I think I
think the standard issue and I think
parents are scared of their kids and it
makes no sense for me for parents to be
scared of kids instead of kids being
scared of parents it's extremely
confusing to see someone like that
taking place but that makes sense that
that has happened America that's
catastrophic for some people that have
kids it's not a a good sign here seven
thousand people arrive on Italian island
of 6 000 as migrant crisis overwhelms
lampedusa okay this is a CNN story this
is in Italy
um
uh lampedusa an Italian island are fewer
than 7 000 residents is grappling with
an overwhelming migrant influx with 7
000 arrivals in two days leading mayor
Filippo manino to State now we have
reached a point of no return with a role
played by this small rock in the middle
of the Mediterranean has been put into
crisis by the dramatic nature of this
phenomenon the U.N Refugee agency Kira
cardoletti emphasized the gravity of the
situation describing it as critical and
stressing the need to urgently relocate
people off the island authorities have
already transferred around five thousand
individuals from lampedusa to the
Italian mainland in the past 28 hours
the search and arrivals many of whom are
escaping political instability in
Tunisia are alarmed have alarmed
officials Tom
look this is this is basically you know
this is this is like the UN just run
amok and by the way they didn't say
revolution in Tunisia they didn't say
genocide in Tunisia they didn't say you
know that there is a flood and now
there's no housing and no working power
plants in Tunisia no it's political
instability in Tunisia so okay so you
know what your place over there really
sucks so we're just going to let you
move Lock Stock and Barrel over here
we're going to take you to Italy and
some Einstein thought it was a good idea
just to drop them on an island where
basically everybody gets to keep track
of one immigrant you know uh everybody
everybody seven thousand of you okay
buddy system pair up with a refugee and
this is how we're going to do this this
is this is horrible this is this is the
same thing by the way no one in Europe
wants to learn from experience do you
see the issues that that Germany is
having right now when they had those
boatloads of immigrants they came into
Germany remember two years ago it went
on for four months they just kept
bringing boatloads boatloads and in the
middle of those boatloads they found
criminals that have found thriving
criminal careers in Germany and they
found a lot of people that wanted to
make it to Germany and make a new life
and find something and get away from
something else I I just think when the
when the U.N is if you don't think
there's one world government coming you
know this is the this is the UN here you
know basically green lighting and then
the EU EU which has tremendous power
over the borders which is the reason for
brexit which is the reason UK says leave
me alone I'm gonna do it my way my rules
this is this is horrible this is this is
unchecked and they and they actually
don't care I think they're actually
trying to to you know Crush structure
and and head for the great reset let me
give you a little perspective here you
know um I get it people want to leave
for a better life safety security future
of your children I get it
um we just talked about you know you
know stop donating money to Ukraine and
stop you know policing the world as an
American the last thing on my list is
lampadesa Italy and the migrant crisis I
don't give two shits okay because
especially in my Democratic friends out
there you might get a little triggered
right now especially with what's going
on in the border right now in America in
Mexico which is a show and when you
have someone like Fareed Zakaria who I
it was probably my favorite journalist
out there who I respect
basically and he's a CNN guy he's like
yeah the Democrats have it all wrong
this is a show if you see what's
going on in New York and the sanctuary
cities and Eric Adams talking about the
decline in New York City whatever is
happening in the U.S border right now is
not good and you got to credit Donald
Trump for bringing this up the problem
that the media basically utilized was
they they
called him a racist and Mexicans are
rapists and all this kind of stuff but
no let's just look at the actual issue
our actual border here in the United
States of America is a show and you
want you could say the Democrats want to
have it so they can open borders so they
can have you know we remember that under
the Biden Administration we came in here
and that's how you got in America and
that's how you're gonna be able to vote
okay that's a long-term play and
everything that's going on with the
dreamers and the anchor babies and
voting future voting at the end of the
day my point is this Italy lampedusa EU
figure it the out we have to figure
our own out over here watch this
year during this entire time newborn
baby found dead on migrant boat off
lampedusa as Italy wrestles with surgeon
Rivals another kid died uh uh that the
right at the top let me read the next
part there at the top keep going up the
baby's death comes days after a
five-month-old boy drowned when a boat
carrying migrants from North Africa
capsized I mean there's Stormville it's
horrible non-stop stories but then who's
paying the price for it to 6 000 people
living on that island it's not even the
island anymore pad there's more of the
other people than there are of you it's
not yours anymore what did they do what
are they at fault they're simple people
on an island trying to make their lives
working and boom because you're part of
this you have to take it and by the way
you heard what erdogan said about EU no
they're considering leaving the EU
erdogan turkey President says you know
what we may be out of here so let me
read this erdogan says turkey may be
part ways with with the EU he implied
the country could end its membership bid
and uh uh could end its membership bid
president uh erdogan said Saturday that
turkey May part ways with the European
Union implying that the country is
thinking about ending its bid to join do
27 Nation block the EU is making efforts
to sever ties with turkey we will
evaluate the situation and if needed we
will part ways with the EU he was
responding to a question
about a recent report adopted by the
European Parliament which stated the
accession process cannot resume under
the current circumstances and calls on
you to explore parallel and realistic
framework for EU turkey relations turkey
applied to join the EU in 1999 the
accession talks began in 2005 and the
accession negotiation were were frozen
in 2018 because of democratic
backsliding according to the e to the
European Parliament how bad is this for
EU is EU sitting there saying we don't
mind losing turkey or you know what do
you see when you see this year Tom now
this is the EU needs everybody right now
because the EU is uh capitalist
demographics oh yeah yeah they're
socialists that's right so they need
more people to tax they need more they
need more places to spread it around and
they they want a unified EU because that
was their that blue flag you know going
back when they started it this was the
plan to bring everybody together knock
down the borders bring it all together
and for someone to step out especially
you know Turkey is kind of like China
and kind of like India there's a lot of
um a lot of low-cost labor there and um
let's go to the next story which is
Vinnie's story Denver homeless Camp
features papa bar with rentable
prostitution tents I don't know why this
is your story but you asked for it so
let's go through the makeshift open air
Tavern has appeared in a downtown Denver
homeless Camp featuring lounge chairs
umbrellas and astro turf prompting
complaints from City officials and
residents to pop-up Speak Easy located
on 23rd Rob if we can get a picture of
video of this and Champa Street has
raised concerns about alcohol sales and
prostitution activities within
encampment
uh Denver Police Patrol Division Chief
Aaron Sanchez acknowledges report of an
open bar in alcohol sales at the
encampment Stadium we're hearing there
was an open bar sales of alcohol things
like that uh Megan Shea an executive at
the homeless eight group step to uh
Denver expressed concerns about the
makeshift bar serving alcohol to unhost
an encampment serving liquor townhouse
I came to this this company
valuetainment your whole thing is
entrepreneurship and capitalism if that
right there doesn't scream it these guys
have an open bar outside like say what
you want at least they're being like
proactive and they're trying to make
money ever people are complaining but
Pat did you say I mean Rob go to that
photo that tent next to the couch that's
the process keep going keep going that
right there so that's the A Guy waits
out there there's there's prostitution
it's like somebody's butt is somebody's
but no other it's actions happening it's
like it's like yeah you see that
somebody's in there
get it down top and me and Tom talked
about this yesterday it's like you can't
make this up and it's it's happening
they haven't taken it down people are
just complaining but that's how you know
Denver has run but then think about it
people are sleeping with prostitutes
then they're gonna wind up getting the
clap or syphilis and guess what we the
people are gonna have to pay for their
oh because they weren't wearing a mask
exactly they're wee-wees we have to pay
for it and it's just it's unbelievable
that we've gone to the point where the
homeless people could set this up and
again all jokes aside set this up and
all people are doing Tom is just there's
complaints to the police and everything
but it's going down it's still happening
I'm just glad with the homeless issue
that's going on in LA and how mess it is
disgusting it is and have a problem I'm
glad we can kind of make light of this
situation here so when I went to Denver
and still hung out at this homeless Camp
last week I mean I'm all about save that
money well wow the savings at this
drinks were like 50 cents prostitutes
were a quarter I mean it's like look I
go down to Columbia from time to time
everything there is 75 off hotels food
drinks partying women whatever it is
yeah it's 75 off at this homeless
encampment in Denver
99 off came with a free shot of
chlamydia which was amazing that was
awesome you got to cut come on as a
businessman I don't know as an
entrepreneur can you imagine like the
sales meetings like Hey listen guys you
better upsell on the liquor and Sarah
only turned three tricks yesterday we
know there's actually a bad precedent
here do you remember when uh this place
called the Mustang Ranch made headlines
and the Mustang Ranch is not outside of
of um Las Vegas and it made rent it made
um headlines because they had failed to
pay taxes the Mustang Ranch it's a
different name no I know what you're
talking about help me out Rob here it
was a Mustang it was that it was that
older white guy who would hang out no no
refused refused to pay their taxes and
they were a brothel out there yeah and
the U.S government operated the Mustang
Ranch for about six months well they
developed a tax plan that was a true
story and they had shirts that said I
got screwed by the government oh that's
brilliant yeah that's brilliant go to
the image of the guy
if you think about it at the end of the
day people talk bad about it
prostitution is the oldest profession in
the world do you know that right that's
a fact prostitution second all this the
pimp was the oldest
no no the pimp was an entrepreneur that
saw what was going on he's like we got
it we know we gotta put a CBA collective
bargaining agreement we gotta get Union
at unionized yeah exactly that was
actually the first one
am I is am I spending the fact probably
not the oldest Farmers I mean come on
but profession come on Wesley all right
let's talk about uh Trump the scientists
here did you guys see Kevin McCarthy
what he said about DeSantis and how
DeSantis responded to it Rob if you got
that video from Kevin McCarthy if you
can play that's right there here's Kevin
McCarthy he's asked about the santis and
Trump this is his answer all of that the
policies that you mentioned of the body
Administration is one reason that Donald
Trump is leading in the polls right now
what's your take on this that as we see
more indictments of Donald Trump he
seems to be gaining in terms of
popularity with the public will he be
the nominee I think he will be the
nominee and the thing is
president Trump is stronger today than
he was in 2016 or 2020. and there's a
reason why they saw the policies of what
he was able to do with America putting
America First making our economy
stronger we didn't have inflation we we
didn't have these battles around the
world we didn't look weak around the
world well it looks like Ron DeSantis is
now trying to work with New York
colleagues who are pushing for a
shutdown yeah but I don't think that
would work anywhere a shutdown would
only give strength to the Democrats it
would give the power to Biden it
wouldn't pay our troops it wouldn't pay
our border agents more people would be
coming across I actually want to achieve
something and this is where president
Trump is so smart that he was successful
in this you know president Trump is
beating Biden right now in the polls
yeah we have the poll let's show it he's
stronger than he has ever been in this
process and look I I served with Ron
DeSantis he's not at the same level as
president Trump by any shape or form he
would not have gotten elected without
president Trump's endorsement and so I
believe our best step forward
so we're stronger
secure our prayer the Santa's response
to him I you know the the clip where Ron
has asked the question Governor DeSantis
and here's his response
uh to what McCarthy said and by the way
you would have to fast forward because
for about for about the first 10 seconds
you don't hear anything the questions
being asked so okay go back a little bit
go back a little bit a little bit a
little bit okay there you go it's first
place
[Laughter]
saying I mean I think that if you look
at what's happened with DC Republicans
if you can raise the audio very closely
you know look Donald Trump he supported
Kevin McCarthy very strongly for speaker
I don't think he would have won the
speaker vote Donald Trump was
instrumental in him earning that speaker
back and they worked and they love
really throughout his whole presidency
on every major spending bill that came
down to the pipe and they ended up
together adding 7.8 trillion dollars to
our national debt never in four years
wow than what they did together and so
he said that we're different we are
different because in Florida we run
budget surpluses we've paid down almost
25 of our state debt just as I've been
Governor all the debt all the way up for
all of Florida's history we've knocked
off almost 25 percent of it so it's a
much different approach uh to where
we're doing it right we have the number
deposit and then he gets asked the
question and he says
uh uh he says uh uh Trump's election
chance is close to zero if he's
convicted of a felony the Santa said
that oh really close to Zero by the way
you're seeing a fight which is good I
love it they should have started earlier
but you're seeing a fight on what's
taking place what he's saying how is he
attacking back Tom do you think the
scientist stands a chance at all of
going ahead of trump like if you were to
say the chances are no felony nothing
does he stand a chance at all
no I I do not and I'll tell you why
forget the felony forget the arrests
Head to Head versus Donald Trump the
polls are speaking but that's what the
problem is what the problem is is he's
run three campaigns the shadow campaign
before he declared and it only was
partly
executed a book launch and in a horrible
initial campaign in which DeSantis
didn't mesh with the voters didn't have
a media management strategy and now he
had that
um house cleaning and he's lost donors
and he's literally on campaign number
three and so I look at it like this dude
none of those have elevated you in the
polls you've only lost in the polls
progressively
I don't it does matter what's happening
to Donald Trump in terms of the
indictments however Head to Head even
without those indictments there is no
chance at for Ron DeSantis and I think
that he's blown the through
opportunities he had the shadow campaign
the first campaign and the current
campaign in fact just a random
observation you notice how calm cool
collected DeSantis is when he's speaking
there smaller crowd I believe I trust
him and I I feel him there when he's on
the big stage it's very robotic and well
you notice that like see how he's
speaking like this is what made people
fall in love with the Santas was during
covet he had very good feedback that he
had this attitude this nice calm talking
he's engaging when he's on the big stage
he looks like he's a robot if you guys
want to watch Governor if you're gonna
watch Newsome last night on CNN if you
didn't watch Newsom last night on CNN
watch it he did a clinic on how to
handle tough questions she kept asking
tough questions he was very good the way
he handled it he that Governor Ron
DeSantis needs to privately when nobody
is around watch newsom's way of handling
issues the way he did yesterday he needs
to watch that on repeat over and over
and over and over again his handling
needs to be learned this guy is I think
Newsom you guys were saying earlier
Clinton was great I think Newsom is more
gifted than Clinton in this area not
policies his policies cost the state a
lot of money his policies cost people to
want to leave his policies got people do
not trust him on the way he's you know
taking care of families his policies you
know almost got him to do recall and you
know what he said at the end he said she
says so any chances of you're going to
be running for a president says me no I
don't have any I'm a governor I'm not
going to be running for president says
heck just a couple years ago they did a
recall on me trust me I've been humbled
very well the last two years people
didn't want me here that's what he said
and by the way you know what I respect I
respect the fact that he said that so
those are the things that he's doing
where he knows how to win the people
over this guy's got a lot of skill
you'll say remember I'm not talking
policies I'm not talking right for the
nation but this is a formidable
candidate for the left to become a
president one day formidable you hit the
nail on the head Pat we have this
conversation all the time where there's
two major indicators of who people are
voting for whether it's policy or
personality I would argue that the
Republicans are way better at policy
there's policy wonks and guys like
DeSantis and they whether Nikki Haley
they lack what Candace Owens called the
it Factor swag Pizzazz personality the
Grizz the whole the sauce you know guys
like Obama have it let's put Biden aside
he was elected because he just wasn't
Donald Trump period but Gavin Newsom has
it his policies have led to a
vacancy of California U-Haul prices are
costs an arm and a leg to get the hell
out of California and calls next enough
to go to California but he's a skilled
politician and don't forget uh Gavin
Newsom with his ID factor is 10 years
older than descendants people forget
DeSantis is 44 45 years old uh he just
okay 45. he's still a young dude you
know he's still got time but look he's
going against something that we have
never seen before with Donald Trump we
talk about you need to duplicate
yourself you can't duplicate a guy like
Donald Trump no go make a billion
dollars in New York and real estate have
a number one show on TV for a decade
have swag be good with the ladies open
up casinos bankruptcy yep that's right I
know how to use the law Democrat
Republican go try to do that Ron
DeSantis so as much as Ron DeSantis has
done a good job during covet for two
years Trump's been doing it for 40. I
gotta tell you though the criticism
around the Santa president Trump got Rob
can you pull up the clip about when
Megan Kelly asked him the question about
can men be men can men be women while
you're doing that I'll read this clip
about China Anna will come back to you
if you can find that clip about on
Twitter so then there were two The
Disappearance of second Chinese Minister
spark speculation Chinese defense
minister Lee Shang Fu who recently
warned of a new period of instability
has mysteriously disappeared from public
view mirroring the earlier unexplained
disappearance of former foreign minister
King Kong in June this development has
raised questions about this about the
stability of President XI ji Ching Bing
cabinet particularly as both a Lee and
Ken were personally chosen by XI making
it this is like a maze guys you got to
track all these names making it
challenging for him to evade
responsibility for the perceived
failures Lee Vanishing act follows
allegations of corruption and U.S
sanctions against him in 2018 for
transactions with individuals linked to
Russia's defense and intelligence
sectors U.S officials believe that
corruption is endemic in the people's
Liberation Army pla undermining ji's
efforts to modernize the military town
I I think you look at this the same way
that we watch
um Russia you know you almost need a
decoder ring with Russia you say what
did Putin say who was standing with him
you know those pictures who's not
standing with them where was he what
were the exact words he used the same
thing is going on in China China is in
the midst of a real estate crash
um it's huge China is a middle middle of
an economic correction has her own
issues on interest rates and Mexico one
week ago we now get a greater percent of
our imports from Mexico than we do China
it's it's all shifting so they've got
this huge economic shift and they've got
this thing going on the world stage and
they desperately want to you know go
take Taiwan and meanwhile the they have
their own form of Shadow government
they've got they've got the
the Communist party that wants to kind
of pull the strings and do things and
now jeez had two guys both of whom had
corruption issues that have been pulled
out because remember it's all face on
that Administration it's all face and
once it looks like you've tripped or
something's wrong and you you you no
longer say face you know this is what
happens and so when you see people
disappearing it's a sign that that area
of government is needs a correction and
what you're seeing is they're making the
correction by basically replacing these
guys in Midstream but they don't do it
as nearly as publicly or as eloquently
as it happens in the west but by the way
whatever happened to Jack Ma
actually what happened to Jack bomb
remember he was discovered to have been
living in I believe it was Rob you can
look this up I believe he lived in Tokyo
for two and a half years and made zero
public statements about the CCP you
gotta understand what happened with Jack
ma we covered that when we were back in
Dallas in 2020 and The Disappearance of
Jackman I did a whole
um segment on that for um
for my show at the time he went to a
re-education camp that's what happened
we know that yes what happened to him
meaning he's just laying low not talking
okay and uh so that's the the reason
that's the bottom lineup that they want
to put Jordan Peterson through that they
wanted in Toronto for different reasons
he needs to be educated on how to talk
to people Etc et cetera okay yeah well
the bottom line is in these countries uh
you just disappear
and uh whether it's for a couple months
a couple years or the rest of your life
you know shout out to Vladimir Putin
um that's what happens in these
authoritarian regimes thank God that's
not what's happened in America at the
very last time not assassinate you
that's what they do here that's not
we're not there yet boy this wouldn't be
a bad thing if we had a strong president
would it no no not at all no if we did
it would be a different situation by the
way play that clip with Megyn Kelly and
Trump making Kelly as president this
question here's Trump's answer that's
got a lot of people on the right upset
can a man become a woman
um
in my opinion
you have a man you have a woman I I
think I think part of it is birth can
the man give birth no no although
they'll come up with something still no
see and Pat everybody's always like
Vinnie you're such a trump guess what I
don't like that answer say what you got
why is that because he's on the fence he
doesn't want to piss off that certain
group for for that for the voting and
it's like you should right then and
there I think that should have been a
moment where he goes your men are men
and women are women that's it and that
come move on kind of going like because
obviously he wants to make everybody
happy he's running for president that
answer I don't like I don't like that he
got to step up at him and say no men are
men and women are women no men I fully
disagree with you I'll tell you why why
if there's anybody that's not worried
about making everybody happy it's Donald
Trump he he don't give a everything
he talks about is these you know fascist
Democrat left he don't give two shits
about the outside of the owl right now
he's running in a primary and running
away with it I agree with you that he
should just be like yeah I don't play
this game what the hell are we talking
about there should have been no um no
pause so I agree with you that he should
have doubled down on this yes and
whether it's Dylan Mulvaney or Bud Light
or whatever but like unacceptable
because that's what his base wants so
I'm just saying he's not trying to what
I disagree with you he's not trying to
appease everybody he should be trying to
appease his base the question before
that in the interview I didn't realize
that was two weeks ago but I watched it
last night was about Caitlyn Jenner and
you know he's like the first time we ran
he goes this wasn't even an issue in
2016. yeah Caitlyn Jenner she wants to
use the female bathroom I don't really
give a whatever he's like I knew
Bruce when he was a man beautiful
beautiful man athletes great guy you
know he was like As Trump does Bruce
said he had full surgeries exactly so
he's not trans not cross-dressing Bruce
said I've had full quote the ship has
sailed my surgery I'm complete so
shout out that was the quote that's what
Caitlyn said to the day
shout out to your dick so the point is
this I think Trump it's it's actually
like put yourself in Trump's position
forget about talking points forget about
what your base wants to hear
what the hell are we even like is it a
man a woman or like this is something
he's so not used to yeah but actually
you know if you see him on the campaign
Trail at his rallies he's you know men
or men women are women he's doing this
yeah I don't know if it was just a
glitch a pause he was just kind of
because he's usually very antagonistic
by the way shout out to Trump going on
Megan Kelly going on MSNBC go taking the
tough questions like you CNN with Kate
and Collins like one thing like you have
to respect about Trump
whether you like him or don't like him
the dude shows up there's no chance that
Joe Biden is sitting down there with
Megan Kelly for an hour Fielding tough
questions Joe Biden won't do that for
five minutes
it's one of those things where you know
Trump
I understand why people don't like him
and I understand why people like him
like it's a double like two things can
be true go for it I I think he should
have been definitive he's always been
definitive and that's what his base
wants be definitive why would have been
so difficult for him to say Megan why
are we talking about this
children are born male or female later
in life they want to have sex change we
have a controversy people want to
cross-dress and call themselves trans
that says
if you have a sex change surgery like
Caitlyn Jenner did okay then maybe
you're part of the way there you still
can't give birth but I don't know why
we're having this conversation what is
this question Tom I've heard you do a
better Trump before but that's all he
had to say and by the way we know what
the base would say thank you yeah and it
doesn't give a lot to the other side
it's like boom Pat how would you have
responded to that basic question what is
a woman I mean it's not even a question
for me I don't even know why we're
having a conversation for me it would
have been a different answer but Trump
uh uh Trump is Trump Trump's going to
give whatever answer he wants to give
and there is always strategy in his he
could have had a conversation with this
Camp 30 minutes prior to that that maybe
one of his advisors told him something
that in his mind he's trying to put his
next move together on the way he's going
to answer and the way he's going to have
a rebuttal to this he's a strategist his
brain is always going on what he's going
to be doing and at the same time uh the
audience right now like the scientist if
DeSantis needed a victory
in the last how long four months three
months he just had a victory this week
yeah this has so far been a good week
for DeSantis his response to Kevin
McCarthy and Trump what he just said to
Megan Kelly last week so in the last 10
days this has been a good week for us
let's see if that changes the polls at
all it won't do anything and when the
debate is next week I want to say in
California California
um by the way Megan Kelly she is
actually a full on real journalist okay
she was asking tough questions she was
respectful we all know what happened in
2016 when she's like you've called women
dogs pigs whatever he's like only Rosie
O'Donnell yeah they addressed it it was
very interesting uh but she is classy
and uh of first class journalist but
like he was a Jones she was a lawyer
with Jones dad because I think that was
the interview was this interview where
she asked about the abortion and the
time and the date or 15 weeks or
something like that yes and he still was
like well we're I don't like he's like
you said I would get people from both
sides I said then and we would come down
with a plan exactly that's for everybody
because what he's doing it he saw that
the abortion what the Supreme Court did
right before the midterms didn't wasn't
what would women in America so he's he's
adjusting based on the case study he saw
with midterms midterms revealed a lot to
to them of where America's at today and
he wants to win so for him he's looking
at strategies on how to win the election
googlers told to avoid using words like
share and bundle according to Bloomberg
working at Google you are told to not
use these words you know apparently
these are curse words if you work at
Google so let me get into the bottom of
this with you in a Washington DC trial
alphabet and Google is accused of
maintaining an illegal Monopoly in
online search government lawyers claim
that Google encourage employees to avoid
creating a lasting records of potential
misconduct such as using Google chat
with the history of feature which
automatically deletes messages after 24
hours Google Chief Economist how varians
Memo from 2003 memo encouraged
discouraged using phrases like cutting
off their Air Supply in 2009 very
unadvised using very using query share
instead of market share query shares to
the market share Google employees were
further instructed to avoid specific
terms and metaphors related to
Anti-Trust issues such as scale Network
effects leverage lockup lock-in bundle
and metaphors involved Wars Sports
winning or losing Tom what's going on
here with Google Google saw this coming
a long time ago because when they were
younger they and then they read the case
study on the Microsoft antitrust suit
where Microsoft used a lot of those
words and more where they leveraged PC
makers who were pre-installing windows
and then they were charging you know
extra fees for it and blocking any other
operating system that's what landed
Microsoft at the hands of the Federal
Trade Commission and the the massive
Microsoft antitrust lawsuit Google knows
history and what they've been attempting
to do is set it up so that they limit
the email and the um they're trying to
limit the the breadcrumbs as much as
they possibly can so they were
attempting to have their people not say
certain things so when the federal
government comes in like they did this
week with the official big this is a
multi-year Extravaganza here this will
take five years at least to play out
folks
they want the federal government to have
very little to go with when they start
going in and looking at what the email
was so all of your employees in the
plane defense that's right where I was
going they started playing defense years
ago because they knew exactly what's
going on with the Microsoft suit nearest
gone by yeah I by the way in any
business you got to play offense you got
to play defense offense is building the
company hiring workers defenses
Insurance we're in the insurance
industry we get it this is for the
assumption that they're going to be
dealing with an Anti-Trust lawsuit if
they're not dealing with it already
whether they're in a monopoly or not did
we establish that it's 50 of the market
as a monopoly 50 okay so obviously
Google is a behemoth
um and they're just trying to play a
little defense right now and they're
trying not to use certain words that
might trigger
what year was this
2011 2011 he was prepping the employees
exactly they saw this this light exactly
I knew it was a way in advance but why
because their offense was like the
greatest show on Turf like the St Louis
Rams in 1999 like they were just they're
killing it they're going gangbusters
make it look closer right so it's like
listen let's you know let's not run up
the score too much let's play some
defense cover the spread don't double it
exactly so listen uh we've all seen like
the Mark Zuckerberg's uh on trial and
the CEO of Google for antitrust and
Monopoly and they're just trying to play
little defense in this situation so are
you guys following this story with Deion
Sanders and his glasses have you have
you followed how much he sold so check
this out
so a coach from the other side says I
don't like it uh you know when a person
has her glasses on and a hat on says I
was Todd when you talk to your parents
you take off your glasses and you take
off your hat when you're talking to
somebody yeah what does Dion do he
doubles down Dion buys these glasses for
every single one of his athletes okay
have you followed this no he gives one
to The Rock he gives one to everybody
these glasses he ends up getting some
kind of I don't know if it's Equity or
some kind of a he's sponsorship with
them they end up selling
1.2 million dollars of these glasses
then four and a half million dollars of
these glasses okay the glasses that he's
been wearing yeah and Rob I want to send
you this article if you type in Deion
Sanders four and a half million that's
the article you want to look at it's uh
uh uh just type in Deion Sanders four
and a half million prime one right there
you can pull that one up and let's see
what that one says that's slightly
different than the one I have
um Dion Sanders sunglasses brand amasses
four and a half million dollars in sales
following a verbal back and forth with
Jay Norville in week three if you want
to go a little lower so we can give the
details they're tired of all that stuff
okay go a little second they're tired of
all that stuff they really are tired of
it and I sat down with ESPN today and I
don't care if they hear it in Boulder I
told them I took off my took my hat off
and I took my glasses off and I said
when I talk to grown-ups I take my hat
and glasses off again the same thing
that's what my mother taught me right
and what does Dion do boom go up a
little bit I think there's a tweet above
it Robbie skipped right there the week
CSU coach said take his glasses off
Deion Sanders has his own line of
glasses with blenders and now has given
a pair of every Colorado players they
don't realize they just help me with
business
[Laughter]
foreign
Rock swearing one Rob if you can pause
it then he gives one to uh The Rock and
he can go back to the story Rob then he
gives one to the rock rocks weren't one
at their last game Rock shows up who
else shows up everybody it was the
biggest thing on on Earth did you
actually see the game uh yeah of course
I saw it okay the game was like they
were down something by 15 points or
something they came back fourth quarter
end up winning it insane games over time
and over time a hit that was made that
was a uncalled forehead late hit there's
a lot of controversy but guess what
they're 3-0 yeah look at The Rock's one
of those glasses look at that well for
the for the younger generation out there
Deion Sanders Bo Jackson are arguably
the greatest athletes of all time I
think so okay you know who Dion said is
the greatest athlete of all time yeah
it's ahead of ahead of the ahead of uh
Bo Jackson have you heard him say no his
cousin
right it was a crackhead you ever heard
him tell the story there's always that
one crackhead that could have made my
cousin who was a crack kid who was the
greatest athlete of all time got a hold
of him yeah I'm telling you he says
Dennis Bo Jackson That's Dion Center
that's what I said but Deion Sanders for
the younger generation they probably oh
he was a former NFL player like nobody
like you think about Tyreek Hill who's
in the NFL these days I know that our
audience doesn't love sports this is a
pop culture conversation
whether whoever you think is the best
player in the NFL most athletic Dion ran
circles around that dude he played
cornerback lockdown like Island shutdown
returns he would do the thing at like
baseball he played baseball Atlanta he
was nasty he was crazy and now he's
raising a new generation he's got two
kids on the team the quarterback who's a
Heisman front-runner 30 yards is a beast
he just put his son on the team he's
probably the top three quarterbacks in
college football right now and what you
don't know is he has another son he has
three sons one is Deion Sanders Junior
who's not playing he's got two other
Sons one is a playing his old position
cornerback same number 21 first play of
the game first quarter
pick six to the house boom like the
beginning of the game he's he's actually
a good father he's a good man he's a
brilliant marketer and he's turning out
to be an amazing coach he went to before
Colorado he went to Jackson State and
dominated there he took this opportunity
people forget when I was I mean a huge
Miami Hurricanes fan there it is right
there his son just beginning of the game
first score bang pick six pick six
Colorado was a Powerhouse football
Stewart all these guys were good Rob
stop the video just change it
um they were competing against national
championship against University of Miami
which The Rock was at the game we got
people like Dwyane Wade being like dude
I've never watched a football game in my
car on my phone but that's what prime
time Dion is doing and he's capitalizing
this but as much as this is a feel-good
story
uh their number I think 16 in the
country right now number 19 I apologize
they traveled to Oregon uh or this
Saturday Oregon is a top ten Oregon is
favored by 21 points so he better sell
some sunglasses this week because they
might be three in one by the time it's
totally random though didn't uh he had
like his foot amputated uh Dion didn't
he not foot toad I don't Rob can you
check if you guys
diabetes is it diabetes friend that's
insane like the Unseen is remember when
we did the uh he had two toes amputated
not legs remember when we did that
uh interview yeah uh obviously people
are doing that was craziest interview of
all time the first hour was a show
the second hour was actually a pleasant
conversation as weird as it was but what
one of the conversations that turned the
the tenure and tone of that conversation
was when I asked him did you see what
Dion said about you to Antonio Brown and
he's like well what'd he say because he
respect everyone respects the hell out
of Dan he goes oh no if you if you sh if
you should make it to the hall of fame
he'll show up for you he doesn't even go
back but he'll go for you he's like oh
really like Dion said that kind of a
thing like he has the respect of
everyone football players fans favorite
song must be the money must be the money
every time I tell him to stop I mean
this guy by the way yeah the right deal
with the pink don't play it don't play
it it was the pink outfit he was soji he
had on that uh uh back in the days yeah
but Dion the other day I made a list
because people are saying the greatest
athletes of all time and everyone oh
you're the greatest athletes of all time
I'm like no there's a difference between
the greatest winner and the greatest
athlete yes those are two different
human beings yeah you're talking about
the greatest winner Tom Brady's not
beating Dion in a race exactly yeah who
me the greatest athlete is this guy I
had him as my number one
where was ball in your time LeBron was
number two but was three wow I believe
LeBron was because LeBron just makes no
sense for him to run as fast as he does
jump as high as he doesn't be as big as
he is and have the physique as he has it
just makes no sense and Bo Jackson pan
you know this is one of my top five
greatest winners obviously obviously
he's in the top five greatest oh no
athleticism when he hit the scene and he
was running up on the left field wall
and people didn't know he threw somebody
out from the warning track yeah to home
and people said the announcers just like
why because they're like I've never seen
anything like that in my life no he was
ridiculous yeah prime time was because
we would watch these dude I was old
enough to watch the fastest you ran the
40 in Tom what's the fastest you ran the
40 in I don't think I ever moved
I can tell you I can tell you my two
mile you know is but uh what was your
two mile my two mile I I got into the
11s seriously that's very good
I don't my my 40 I never really timed my
40 but my two mile was insane in the
military like you and it was like Pat I
was Sprint my energy I would just Sprint
the whole thing what was uh yours Pat my
two mile no you're 40. my my 40. I was I
was a four six four seven forty I was a
fast guy yeah yeah you had speed I had
speed what was yours you're a four four
five no well I played college football
but I ran a four five nine if I could
have got it down to four three lower
yeah which it was not possible but four
four three is insane you go for this guy
four two seven but it's uh well Adam saw
my 40 at in Vegas and I tore my your
40th birthday
pull up the tweet I just gave you this
this is what you know we do stories like
this at the end of the podcast story
because this is officially for us folks
for those of you that could care less
about sports we kind of like sports this
is who I had as my top five athletes
zoom in a little bit let me see this
let's go to the bottom go to the bottom
first show the other guy on the bottom
brewski had this he had Serena Williams
at five this is athletes athletes if
they should change it to Winners yet
Serena then Brady then Ruth and Ali then
Jordan right those are ones go to the
time that's like icons I had Dion
Sanders then LeBron them Beau Jackson
then Jordan then I had Jim Brown and
Will Chamberlain Will Chamberlain was a
was a machine when you read about the
guy and Jim Brown was obviously insane
the greatest dominators MJ and Brady had
won then I have Messi Ali Woods Ruth is
who I have and I like Pat he's just
making up the two guys will be at the
first thing that's MJ and Brady to me
it's uh yeah there it goes if you say
he's the Brady of this or he's the MJ of
this yes but Pat you are right there's a
difference between a pure athlete versus
a winner versus an icon night and day
right yeah because the winner has could
have like like Brady he's a great
quarterback but the whole system around
them from the coach to the wide
receivers to the line to everybody look
well let's get real here Tom Brady is
not a top 1000 athlete of all time pure
athlete winner heart of a champion in
icon
Mount Rushmore and I think that's what
you're basically solving for is
by the way on on Tiger Woods if he
doesn't hit a fire hydrant it takes six
years off of his career he would have
shattered not just beaten shattered
Nicholas's records yeah absolutely
that's why you got to be careful who you
marry bro well and also you decide that
maybe you're gonna go be a member you
want to be a Navy SEAL you're reading
the book they actually injured
themselves now you've got to be decide
who you marry you know when you do and
you're not done take your time you know
what I'm saying but if you're like
you're marrying and you want to have 16
folks from the uh you know modern day
Olean fans back in the days you know
adult it's it's a different game that
you play you know what would be
interesting here can we pull that list
back up
I want to know how many of those guys
the greatest of all times yeah the
winners the athletes the icons how many
were married not married divorced had
situations going on on the low I don't
know uh Lebron at the top of the list
he's married to his high school
sweetheart respect to him Michael Jordan
remarried actually a Miami girl that I
know well but I could talk about I mean
Messi's married but you talk about Tiger
Woods Taco Taco Woods y'all homeboy was
playing out there so was Babe Ruth yeah
Muhammad Ali wasn't exactly you know
that tiger was number one until they uh
they got mad at him for the hookers and
the strippers then once that got
everything went down poor guy dude they
should have just left let them hook up
with the strippers and he would have
stayed number one just let him just let
him yeah I think his wife who became a
100 million uh dollar woman 90 minutes
probably had something to say about that
she's amazing she was a goddamn au pair
and now she's worth a hundred million
dollars God bless her soul yeah how many
random dudes just are worth a hundred
million dollars because they got wiped
up by some chick zero and Pat I don't
know if you guys know this or nothing
I'm the dude playing the dude
but think about what do you mean you
people this is random because I don't
know why we thought of because tiger do
you guys remember what happened though
why the whole fight happened and
initiate everything Tiger's home
drinking he's a home with his wife the
stripper called the house okay so he
runs out he gets one house phone's worth
no I'm being dead serious yeah and his
wife he's in the in that truck she's
beating yes the car with the golf club
and I thought how funny it would have
been made the U-turn into the fire
hydrant but think about it his wife is
hitting it with the golf club this is
Tiger Woods the best golfer of all time
yeah you think because he was drunk as
she's hitting it he's like baby wait a
minute
you're not babe I'm sorry but you're a
reflection of your neighbors are
watching it that's my it's my three
hours by the way he wasn't seen for two
weeks and he's a people that are
commentators who know things in golf
says he got hit he got of course the
reason that no one saw him for two weeks
he said he got hit but Neighbors said
her follow flu shot was horrible and it
looked like it looked like she ended up
in the beach gang okay all right so here
we go this is fun tomorrow tomorrow 9
A.M Tom Brady's interview premieres race
for impact Thursday we have a wild uh
discussion here on the podcast myself
with four folks that'll be here it'll be
interesting tune in and we will be doing
many more of those because I feel
eventually I want to have the biggest
representative of the Muslim Community
with the biggest representative of the
Jewish community and the biggest
representative of the Christian
Community for us to do podcasts together
maybe even a live discussion together
and see what we can discuss and unify
see what there is in common and what
differences we have anyways have a great
day everybody tune in tomorrow and
Thursday take care bye bye bye-bye sick